مساء الخير
كتير سالت حالي متل ما اكثر عم يسالوا
حالهم شو بدي اجي اقول هي المنصه
هل المنصه اللي وقف عليها علماء مؤثرين
وملهمين
وانا شخص عادي
عادي
مين قال انه الشخص العادي ما بيقدر يكون
مؤثر
اول شخص اثر فينا هي امنا هي شخص عادي
ابونا
شخص عادي
انستا بالمدرسه دكتورنا بالجامعه حتى
الشخص اللي وصلني لهون
هو شخص عادي
هون ابتسمت وهي الابتسامه
رح نتلث ثقه
وعصير الابتسامه راح احكي لكم على اهم
اربع ابتسامات
سرقوا بحياتي
الابتسامه الاولى
كنا صغار خمس اولاد
عم ناكل برغل بندوره بطنجره صغيره بالخبزه
الاولى
ثانيه
ثالثه
كانت خالصه الطنجره
طلعت بماما
اكلتي
قالت
انا كنت بعرف
انه هي ما اكلت
الابتسامه الاولى اللي سرقها الفقر
بعد فتره من الزمن بنهايه المرحله
الابتدائيه
وبدايه المرحله الاعداديه
اشتغلت بمكان لصناعه اللوحات الاعلانيه
هذا المكان اللي كنت اصغر واحد فيه
بالورشه قالوا له روح جيب صندوق العده
هاد الصندوق يلي كان وزنه ضعف وزني بالضبط
انا عم بسحبه ضرب باحدى اللوحات
وقعت علي
كسرت لي صف الثاني
والشغل اللي مو بوقته
خسرني الابتسامه التانيه
مش الوقت خلصنا دراسه
بلشنا شغل وكان زمان خير
فتحت اول شغل لالي وكان مكتب للصناعه
الاتصالات البصريه
فجاه اجت الحرب
هاي الحرب يلي سرقت الابتسامه الثالثه مثل
ما سرقت ابتسامات كتير ناس
بوقتها
الابتسامه الثالثه اضطريت
غير مجال عملي بشكل كامل
اشتغلت بكافيه صغيره موجوده بدمشق قديمه
هاي الكفاءه
كانت مكان سكني وشغلي بنفس الوقت اشتغلت
فيها كل شيء
تنظيف محاسبه تنظيم فعاليات شبابيه
مبادرات مجتمعيه
وفجاه هون
جاني تليفون
الو
نوار اسكندر
اهلك توفوا
هاي الابتسامه الرابعه
اللي سرقها الموت
الموت
اللي سرق معه السند
ولما يروح السند
بضعف عنا الشغف
ما عاد عنا
قدره نعمل شي
بهذيك الفتره خسرت كل شي عم بعمله لدرجه
ما عاد معي اجور سكن
سكنت في مكان صغير
بحاره مخبايه بالشام القديمه مكان لا يصلح
للسكن البشري غلا مترين بمتر مجاري
الجيران عم تنقط عليه اسبوع كامل
عم باكل
خبز يابس تجيني مجفف
اجاني حدا من اصدقائي قال لي في احد
المؤسسات فاتحه شاغر وحابب انك تقدم عليه
هذا الشاغل
اللي قدمت قالوا لي انقبلت رحت لحتى
استلموا لازم اعمل ورشه تدريبيه مدتها 15
يوم
15 يوم بسبب ضعف الماده عم روح مشي وجهي
مشي عشره كيلو متر يوميا
سنه تشتغل اللي كان باحد
كان شغل باحث مجتمعي
اللي بهذا الشغل رح يكون معي تماس مباشر
مع الناس الناس اللي فادة كتير ابتسامات
اللي فات عيلته فقد دراسته او فقد
قطعه من جسمه
كان شغل الاساسي انا والفريق اللي عم
بشتغل معه انه رجع ابتسامات هاي الناس
اللي فاقد عيلته
رح نكون الدعم
لفائده دراسته رح نعوضه
اللي فاقد بيته رح نحاول نعطيه بدل سكن
لفائد
جزء من جسمه
طرف اصطناعي
تطورنا بالشغل لدرجه منا مشروع كان
الشعار تبعه لنزرع بسمه سلام
وقفت بيني وبين حالي
انه كيف شخص فاقد كل هاي الابتسامات
عم يقدر يعطي العالم سامعات كتير
هون بنعرف
انه فاقد الشيء
يعطيه
يعطيه بشده
بس لحتى يعطيه بشده في كلمه سحريه نعم لكن
كلياتنا نحن يوميا وقتنا في الصبح وحتى
نحط راسنا على المخده
هاي الكلمه السحريه اسمها السعي
هذا السعي جزء كبير
بيعملوا بجهد مبعثر
وجزء لحتى يوصل بيعمله بوعي
او مثل ما بحب اقولها
من وعي
ليش من وعي
الميم
من مجد
نون
من نوار
الواو من وسام العين من علي
اء من يوسف عيلتي
لفقتها الحرب
راح تهديكم ابتسامه موجوده
تحت الكرسي اللي قاعدين عليه
كان معكم نوار اسناندر مؤسسهم